6 45 on your monday morning hey there  was a real happy 100th birthday party in  boulder city  oh the boulder city senior center was  buzzing at lunchtime last friday now the  last friday of every month is a birthday  party there but this time one of the  partners was turning 100  gwen davidson  she even got an amazing special shout  out from across the pond yeah a real  birthday greeting from her majesty  queen elizabeth  you go  gwen yeah it was quite a party she was a  little bit overwhelmed but a shout out  to her son and grandson for inviting me  out to the birthday party and everybody  at the boulder city senior center for  you guys i found out there's a lot of  eight news now viewers oh